ici michael price je suis un agent de
protection et je vient d'extraire mon
client nettoyage demandé l'équipe de
déminage ne serait pas de refus
ou alors les pompiers c'est ma voiture
j'en ai peur monsieur veuillez vous
asseoir la journée avec le premier
il s'agit d'un des pires dictateurs au
monde nous avons un témoin clé qui va
venir à la barre je peux vous promettre
qu'on est préparé à tout même à cela
kinta il sera mort pour recevrez la
totalité de la somme
il ya une planque pas loin d'ici
j'aime mission pour toi le colis à
transporter la planche mais c'est quoi
ça
27 fois c'est le nombre de fois où il a
essayé de me tuer 27 ou 28 serait plus
en sécurité tout seul tu ne survivra pas
une heure sans moi dites nous où est
votre mari vous avez perdu en ont marre
et vous savez à quel point vous avez les
recours
seul moyen pour que bright et une kate
ne s'en sortait pas
c'est qu'ils s'entretuent
ça ne me dérange pas le flingue
non c'est pour bientôt
bon allez à 3
je suis désolé très désolé
dieu vous garde ce mec a déjà tué plus
de 150 personnes quand facile